joining me now is stephen miller former
senior advisor to president trump and
founder of america first legal kurt
schlichter senior columnist at
townhall.com and author of the book
we'll be back and charlie kirk founder
of turning point usa and author of the
great book
the college scam
all right stephen i want to come to you
first and i appreciate you guys all
joining me
joe biden is basically saying that that
it's acceptable to target republicans
with the full force of the federal
government even using the fbi
well that's exactly what he's saying
let's not forget this is the party that
locked people in their homes in blue
states and blue cities they took away
people's most essential freedoms at this
very moment in time they're masking
children in democrat cities like
philadelphia deprive them of an
education mariel bowser is depriving
black students of the right to even
attend school because they haven't
received a vaccination and of course
this is an administration that has
launched a political raid of his chief
political opponent's home
to seize and steal his property and his
documents so what you are seeing is a
classic technique of tyrants and
authoritarians
where they use the methods of
dictatorship while accusing their
opponents of being fascist this
administration is authoritarian and
repressive this administration is
violating our laws including violating
our immigration laws with impunity and
helping murderous criminal cartels
violate our sovereignty every single day
you know it's rich to call republicans
fascist charlie i mean i look at this
and he's talking about the maga movement
which i know people well who support
donald trump i think the whole panel
does and these are people who believe in
god country
faith hard work patriotism they you know
they salute the flag they stand up for
the national anthem these are
traditional americans and they're
calling them fascists
and their language is precise for a
reason i mean what if you actually
encountered a fascist then what wouldn't
you do against that person they're
calling half the country fascists
because then that justifies a patriot
act 2.0 type response be able to spy
infiltrate monitor subvert political
groups that they don't like you see this
is the problem with what's happening
right now the democrat party their
regime is falling apart their policies
are unpopular people are realizing how
transparently awful they are at
governing the only thing they have left
is the power of the few against the many
the fbi the doj facebook google and the
way they're able to do that is call half
the country fascist stephen said it
perfectly they're the fascists if they
all of a sudden want to start to use
every comparison from the 1930s then
fine which are the ones that are using
the fbi for political purposes as steven
said locking people in their homes and
doing favors for their political donors
fascism is state control of business and
boy does it look like joe biden is using
government for his cronies and his
business purposes against the will of
the american people charlie you make a
good point because if you had something
to run on if you had a a record to run
on you would run on it but if you look
at inflation gas border crime
afghanistan joe biden has nothing to run
on so what does he do he attacks uh
republicans with you know outrageous
terms like this but kurt i want to come
to you the dnc chair jamie harrison was
asked about the biden semi-fascist
comment and how that squared with his
calls for unity watch
the one thing that president joe biden
has been has always been consistent and
he has always been somebody who
does what my grandfather used to do
which is speak it plain say it plain to
the american people and what we see
right now is a full frontal attack by
these extreme
mega republicans in this country
he's consistent kurt
what say you
oh he's he's consistent all right sean
he's been a consistent [ __ ] through 50
years in washington and now he's a
senile one as well look i don't need to
be lectured on
patriotism by some guy who uh got out of
military service uh from a k with a case
of asthma that disappeared as soon as
the draft did i deployed for my country
two times i don't need to be questioned
by this hack or any of his hack friends
like uh uh uh
like like this clown
this is incredibly dis destructive this
is incredibly destabilizing look i
served in places where the norms fell
away where the system fell apart where
it turned into conflict because one
group decided want power and it didn't
care what it had to do to get it that's
what these guys are doing this is
dangerous and it's also a and it's more
than dangerous it's squandering the
inheritance that we receive
uh
from the americans that came before who
built this country into the freest most
prosperous most powerful country that
ever existed it's a disgrace it you know
if he wasn't so manifestly senile i'd
expect him to be ashamed of himself but
he can't do that there's no excuse for
his minions though they should know
better it's obnoxious no kurt you're
right because when you start to break
these norms um you start to do things
that we've never done in our past
it's really hard to you know put things
back together because what now you say
well democrats have done this to
republicans do republicans go back to
the norm or do republicans actually do
this back to democrats i mean things
start to devolve but stephen this is not
the first time democrats have talked
like this go back to barack obama when
he said you know republicans cling to
their bibles and their guns or hillary
clinton
called republicans or trump supporters a
basket of deplorables this demeaning
derogatory language trying to otherize
republicans
yeah so i want to pick up on something
to that point that charlie said which is
that you're setting the stage with this
rhetoric to use the awesome power of the
state
to persecute
political dissenters to persecute
traditional americans faithful americans
conservative americans bible-believing
americans just like you saw garland
weaponize the department of justice to
go after parents objection to critical
race theory you're going to see them
using the powers of the security state
to surveil americans to censor americans
to silence americans in full collusion
with big
tech and so you are going to see if we
don't throw the radical left out of
power you're going to see our civil
liberties stripped away in this country
and i think that's something that should
terrify all americans i don't care if
you're republican i don't care if you're
democrat when biden talks this way about
people he disagrees with he is saying
any tactic any measure
anything would be justified because
these people are evil that is truly
frightening you know you're right
stephen we protect the rights of people
that we disagree with adamantly disagree
with because that's the way the system
works
um charlie we're already seeing the
effects of what biden said today
rnc chairwoman roman ronna mcdaniels
tweeted out this picture writing the
seminole county gop office was
vandalized overnight that criminals
echoed biden's fascist slander the gop
will not be intimidated charlie are you
expecting to see more of this uh with
biden's rhetoric and democrats acting on
that rhetoric
yeah unfortunately yes and we see this
on college campuses all the time when i
visit college campuses i see the
increase of violence and hatred and you
look at what's happening on colleges as
almost the wuhan lab equivalent of the
places where this sort of behavior is
incubated where where do you think that
idea of where fascism and the idea of
fighting fascism comes from it comes
from uc berkeley and stanford and yale
that's where it becomes cool and then it
germinates the rest of society so
unfortunately i do expect the kind of
violence to continue we have to remain
peaceful on our side but i do think that
if they're gonna escalate the language
then game on like okay if you're gonna
call us a bunch of fascists we're not
gonna take that anymore you're the
fascist joe biden and there's other
words we could use as well we're not
gonna be like well i'd like to go back
to the time of 2014. i'm sorry it's over
that's done they're calling you the
worst thing that could be called
indecent political conversation and what
are we gonna do like oh well we need to
find a common ground no we have to win
we have to displace these people from
power right now
pay attention
this this is the rubicon that's been
crossed when they call half the country
fascists government society politics all
devolves kurt uh 20 seconds final word
to you
look sean this isn't this isn't
happening because they're winning this
is happening because they're losing and
they're desperate look at the uh uh look
at the approval polls uh biden is
pulling right up there with monkey pots
okay these guys you know these guys have
lost in virginia they're losing at the
school boards uh hispanic americans are
flocking to the republican party because
it's the party of faith family and the
flag just like hispanic americans love
uh they are desperate and they're and
the problem is when somebody's desperate
he does stupid things and of course you
you multiply that by uh joe biden who's
made a career of doing stupid things uh
we're we're gonna have a bumpy ride
you know you're right americans still
love freedom and the rule of law stephen
kurt charlie thanks for joining me hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else